[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER: Let's dive in.
We're going to give this talk
about serverless ML solutions.
And up here on stage,
we have Vikram Tiwari,
co-founder of Omni Labs.
VIKRAM TIWARI: And
we have Martin here,
who is developer
advocate at Google Cloud.
And to get started,
what is Omni Labs?
So Omni Labs is a company
which is a startup based here
in San Francisco.
We are building tools
to simplify and automate
repeatable tasks.
So repeatable tasks, you
can think of-- the example
that we are going to do
today is based on analytics.
One of the analytics
tasks that marketers do,
they get data from
various sources
while at vendors where
they run their campaigns.
And they download those reports.
And they have to get
those into central place
to take a look at the
analytics of all those reports
that they're getting from
different ad vendors.
So a few engineering things
that we keep on our side
as a [INAUDIBLE]
engineering team is,
keep everything simple.
Make things scale on demand.
And use machine learning
to augment the uses
that we have of our technology.
A machine learning
solution is more than just
building a model.
Anyone can build a model.
And we see so many of those
come up on GitHub every day.
But when we are talking
about an end-to-end solution,
it involves more than
just the model itself.
MARTIN OMANDER:
What amount of work
do you think you put it
into this sort of data
engineering versus building the
model, do you think, Vikram?
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah,
actually, building the model
itself is really easy.
Because it's-- most of the time,
you are just taking a paper
that has recently published,
because you wantto always be
updated.
And then you cut it down.
You take the mathematics
that is in the model
to transform it to your
Python function-- or maybe
if you are using Swift
or something else.
And convert that model--
converting that model code is
not actually really hard.
It's mostly like
getting your data
to work with that model,
which takes more time.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah,
as we are talking--
going to be talking
about here today,
when you are building
this complete product,
it takes a lot more to do that.
Because you have to extract
and clean your data.
You have to do that
over time in a pipeline.
You have to do--
and apply extra data
transformations.
Because those are
your new features
that you have to apply.
Then you have to
manage this whole model
pipeline that is there.
So the configuration
management of that,
you're doing using
hyperparameter
tuning and similar things.
And then, your models
are not good enough
unless they can actually
give value to the user.
So you have to provide on-demand
predictions to the users.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right, and
this never stops, right?
VIKRAM TIWARI: This never stops.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, you don't
build a model, and you're done.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
So a product is like-- it's not
a one-time proof of concept.
You have to build the model
and keep the machine running.
And there's new data coming in.
There's new machine learning
models getting out there.
And you have to constantly
give the value to the client.
So for that, this
is a whole pipeline.
This is not a one-stop--
one-way-- or one process.
So there are a few engineering
challenges that we had to face.
We categorized it
into four parts.
And that's how we'll
be walking today,
through the presentation.
So first is extracting and
transforming your data.
So extracting the data--
we are doing this via APIs
from these vendors.
These APIs have limitations
that you cannot extract data all
the time.
It's not a socket-based API.
Or every vendor will have
different restrictions.
You have to have
quotas on those APIs.
And we have to
honor those quotas.
Otherwise, we will get blocked.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, it
sounds like that might
have happened in the past.
VIKRAM TIWARI:
Yeah, you know it.
So then, all the data, that
raw data that you get it,
you have to also
transform that data.
So you have to transform the
data for multiple use cases.
Because analytics
is, today's use case.
What's next?
Machine learning, of course.
Then, once you have
all of this data,
you want to store that
in a central location
where you can use it for
reporting as well as analytics
use cases.
And then you can store it all
for use cases of analytics,
but your queries
might become slow.
So you have to make sure
that your queries are always
performant.
And they should always
be returning the results
in a performant way.
Users don't want slow queries.
Nobody loves that.
And keep the cost low as well.
So you want to scale
up the servers.
We'll talk more about that.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, Omni
Labs is a startup, right?
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: So you're
looking at costs quite a bit.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Almost all day.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right, and
we'll see more about that,
and how to manage costs,
and make this all efficient.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
Then, once you
have all the data,
you have to actually build your
models and keep them updated.
Keeping the model
updated is not just
keeping the model code updated.
Of course, you have to update
your Python dependencies
all the time.
But you have to also make sure
that it's getting the new data.
There is always--
our advertisers,
they're actually running
the campaigns every day.
So you want to get all that data
every day, or as much frequency
as you can, and generate
the newer model.
Because your model is
as good as the data
that is getting in there.
Then, you also have
to manage retraining,
because there are new
clients that are coming in.
You want to use one central
model for all the clients.
Or you want to generate new
models out of those models--
the central model that you have.
And of course,
hyperparameter tuning,
who doesn't want to do that?
You never can build a
good model by yourself.
You have to use hyperparameter
tuning to get the best
hyperparameters.
And finally, all
of this is no value
unless you can serve this, in
real time, to your clients.
So managing authentication--
which client
gets access to which model that
you have in-house, depending
upon how much they're
paying, and all of this
managing in real-time
predictions.
And this traffic
is very infrequent,
as we will talk
more in the talk--
more in the presentation today.
MARTIN OMANDER: Excellent.
So with this, a lot of this
can be done in serverless.
You have all heard-- we've
all heard about serverless.
And serverless
computing-- there's
one part of serverless
that gets most
of the press, most of the blog
posts, most of the attention.
And that is the central
part of the figure
here, the compute part.
So serverless computing,
just as a quick recap--
in the Google Cloud Platform,
you could do Cloud Functions.
If you have just very simple
pieces of code functions,
you can string them together.
Or if you want to
deploy something bigger,
like a full application, you
would run those on App Engine.
Yesterday, you may have
heard the announcement
about Cloud Run.
That is the third hexagon
we see there in the middle.
This allows you to upload,
deploy a container,
and run that serverlessly.
So serverless compute--
OK, we kind of
know what that is.
But there's so much else--
so much more-- to serverless.
Because we, as developers, want
to solve business problems, not
engineering problems.
So that becomes a lot
easier if we do computations
serverlessly, but also if we
do data analytics, database
storage, ML, devops, messaging.
All these other things can
be done serverlessly as well.
And we'll see some cases here
where Vikram will tell us
how his startup, Omni
Labs, achieved greater dev
velocity by going serverless
on some of these other pieces
as well, not just Compute.
So first, we have--
Vikram was mentioning--
extracting and transforming
the data.
So these data
pipelines, as we heard,
they extract the
data from the APIs.
They clean it, merge
it with other data.
And we have some
engineering challenges here.
It's not just a simple
FTP import or something,
and you're done.
VIKRAM TIWARI: GPN portal, man.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yep.
VIKRAM TIWARI: So we are
getting all this data
from different APIs.
We have to clean it.
Of course, there's
feature engineering
that you have to do.
And the biggest challenges
that we faced on our side
was the variability
of the data size.
Because there could
be a client which
is running a very
small campaign,
so they are getting
10 entries a day,
versus there could
be a client, which
is running thousands of
campaign across geographies,
and we are getting thousands
of entries per hour.
So data size varies
from client to client.
Plus, frequency of data
ingestion could also vary.
There could be somebody who is
not running any campaigns right
now.
We don't want to keep machines
up for those ingestions.
Or there could be somebody
who is running this
and wants this data
every few hours.
And we want to make sure that
our solution can deliver this
to them.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
you couldn't have
a sort of one size fits all.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Is that
what made this hard?
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah, so--
yeah, so what we tried
was, we tried to--
as soon as you have a data
problem, first thing you do,
you write up Python code, put
it in our virtual machine.
So we tried that, but there
were multiple issues there.
What could happen is we could
allocate access compute.
So if there was--
data size was
really small and we
had given it a 10-CPU machine,
eh, not really required.
Sometimes it might be
a really big data set,
and we didn't look at enough
CPU or enough RAM in there.
And RAM is not compressable, so
it crashes the whole machine.
That also happens.
Sometimes this whole
process, since it's
happening in a chain
process, joint chain manner--
first, we get the
data on one machine.
Then we transform it
on another machine.
Then we pass it forward
to the third machine
to push it into different
storage sections--
this whole process
is chained together
with different scripts.
And if one of those breaks,
the whole system collapses.
It's very brittle.
And the collapses-- any breaking
causes cascading collapses.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hmm, so this,
is of course, managed VMs,
as we heard.
There is another way to,
potentially, doing this.
With Cloud Dataflow, you
don't manage servers.
It can take batch
or streams of data
and then serverlessly,
dynamically
allocate these jobs--
so across physical machines.
And you don't really see
the physical machines
or manage them much.
Would that be something that
would be useful for Omni Labs?
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah, so
that's why, actually, we
ended up doing.
So we ended up
utilizing Dataflow.
And with Dataflow, what
we were able to do is
we were able to launch as many
jobs as we can in parallel.
So we split off our jobs
into smaller chunks.
As you can see from the
image, we launched, like,
10 jobs within a minute.
And all of those 10 jobs
are running in parallel.
And if one of those
jobs fails, it
doesn't cause any issues with
another job that is running.
So other systems
can keep running,
and one individual
job fails by itself.
Also, all the machines,
since they are--
they're scalable by themselves.
So if your job runs in
seven minutes or seven days,
your machines can keep alive.
System scheduler will
take care of that.
And they can scale up and
down as your data flow
transformations are happening.
MARTIN OMANDER: You had jobs
that ran for seven days?
VIKRAM TIWARI: A few, and
some for more than that.
MARTIN OMANDER: More than that?
VIKRAM TIWARI: I didn't have
the screenshots for those.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow,
that's a big job.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
Yeah, so we were doing most
of these as batch jobs.
We have started doing most of
these, now, as streaming jobs.
So it's always running machines.
There are some people who
have done these jobs where
the machines have been
running for years now.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
So while doing this, we came
into touch with Apache Beam.
Apache Beam is the
programming model
that you use to
transform your data
and run this on a
Dataflow pipeline.
Apache Beam provides you
an out-of-box methods.
So there's reading from a file,
or splitting your data into--
or creating a flatMap.
Plus, you can create
your own functions
and apply those into the--
utilize those custom
functions as well.
The best thing about Apache
Beam is your pipeline options,
as you can see on the top.
If you want to take
it away from GCP,
you just change
pipeline options,
and you are on your local
machines, another cloud
provider, or anywhere
else you want to run it.
And it's just change
of configuration.
Your code never changes.
MARTIN OMANDER: You
would, of course,
never want to take
it off of GCP.
But just in case, it's nice
to have an escape hatch.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER:
All right, so yeah,
you should never be a prisoner--
if your cloud platform,
whatever vendor you're using,
is keeping your data and
code prisoner on there,
then it's probably
not a place to be.
You want to always be able
to have the escape hatch.
It's sort of like, if
you're on a plane, right,
you probably don't want to use
the emergency exits too often.
But it's good to know
that they're there.
So the next step Vikram
was telling us about
is filling the data lake.
So data lake is
this pattern where
you getting the data
from various resources
like these APIs, external APIs.
And instead of crunching
it as you are importing it,
you just store it
all in raw form.
Then, when you
need to-- when you
have certain data needs, or
reports, or machine learning,
that's when you
apply the transforms.
That means that you
can do things like--
I want to have everything by
week, and grouped by week.
Or the next month, you want
everything grouped by hour.
And you can get that, because
you have all the raw data.
So the data lake is the central
source for all your raw data.
And you saw some real challenges
here with filling the lake.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
Yeah, as I mentioned
already, there
could be thousands of entries
which could come in every hour.
So what you want is a
really good ingestion system
which is write-heavy.
And then you also
want to make sure
that your analytics can
aggregate really quickly.
Because you are
going to be doing
a lot of operations on different
times and different window
options.
Plus, you also want to
be able to do modeling
on top of this data.
So you will have
different-- window sessions
could be really huge.
It could be years of
data that you could be
using to do the modeling patch.
So the initial approach that
we went with was dump and pray.
So we took all the data
that we were getting in
through our pipelines
and pushed all of that
into BigQuery straight up.
And we demanded
BigQuery to scale up,
because BigQuery is BigQuery.
The issues that
we faced in there
were, anytime we had to update
old data, it's a trouble.
There are update
operations in BigQuery,
but you don't really
want to do those.
Those are really costly,
and limitations are there.
Plus, every time we
were querying the data,
we were querying
all of the data.
So the way BigQuery
works is, whenever
you are querying
a column, it has
to go through all of the
values in that column
unless you limit it via
some certain limitations.
Plus, as we are storing
all of this data
from years worth of their
campaigns, it keeps--
the storage costs
keep getting add up.
So we want to reduce that
storage cost as well.
So as you can see here, a query
that ran on a small table,
it cost us 32 MB to
process that data.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
the 32 megabytes here
is data that is pulled in?
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah, just
because we are querying
one of the columns in there.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, and you are
not-- perhaps not even using--
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah--
MARTIN OMANDER:
--all of that data?
VIKRAM TIWARI: --perhaps we only
want to use the first tendrils,
because I want to
only understand
what happened in the last hour.
I don't need to get
all the data in there.
But there's no way to put the
limits around that right now.
MARTIN OMANDER: So I see.
And you typically-- you
have time series data.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER:
And you typically
are more interested
in the newer data.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Generally, yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Generally.
VIKRAM TIWARI:
Clients don't want
to see the historical
data unless they
were doing a meeting in
end of the month, yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
yeah, and sometimes they
want to see it all--
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: --but most of
the time, just the new stuff.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
for that one, there
is a technique called
date partitioning.
So basically, you
have this big table.
But within BigQuery, you can
tell BigQuery to partition
on date, for example.
And internally, BigQuery
sort of splits it up
into many small tables so you
don't have to query them all.
Would that be a good
fit for Omni Labs?
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
Yeah, so that's what
we ended up doing.
We ended up with the approach
of divide and conquer.
So we took our data
as it was coming in,
we split it into the
date chunks as it
is coming in based upon the
date that we got the data.
We split it and put it
into that partition.
And using that, we could
actually ingest a lot of data,
even if it's a historical data.
Earlier, we were like, we don't
want to ingest all this data,
because it's going to be costly.
Now we could ingest
all the data,
because BigQuery allows
you to store all the data.
And if you're not
querying on that,
they reduce the
pricing for you--
win.
Who doesn't want that?
It's an easy win.
Plus, now that I'm querying
on these partition tables,
I can very easily limit
those to a particular vendor.
So as you can see
in the query, we
are partitioning it
to just 2018 data.
Even if I'm querying two
years' worth of data,
I've already reduced the size
from 32 MBs of query to 9.7 MB
of query.
Query runs faster, gives
me the result faster,
and the costs are cheap.
So I'm saving not
only in the storage,
I'm also saving on the
queries that I'm making.
MARTIN OMANDER: And you
mentioned there was--
this older data is
cheaper to store?
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah,
yeah, so after 30 days--
if I'm not getting
the number wrong--
if you don't access the data--
if you don't update the data--
you can still access the data.
Accessing the data never gets--
like, there's no latency.
You won't see the latency there.
But it just becomes
cheaper since you're not
updating that data anymore.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, that's nice.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
we talked, here,
about-- we heard about
partitioning by date,
putting limitations on date.
There is, of course, this
general purpose database
that allows you to do all
that that is not BigQuery.
So there is just plain, old
SQL databases you could run.
And you can put limits on
when you run queries on those.
Could you tell us a little
bit about why you're not going
with a plain SQL solution?
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah,
so SQL solution
would have been perfect.
Because what you can do is,
next day, when you get the data
and you see the
numbers are different,
you can just go and
update that number value.
But SQL solutions are
really easy to get setup,
but really hard to scale.
Think of, right now, it could
have started with a small SQL
instance.
But as soon as I get more
data, I need more disk space.
As soon as I have more
clients which are querying,
I need to scale up
my cluster, because I
need more RAM in there.
I need more CPU.
When there are a lot
of clients doing this,
and they want to
do this frequently,
I want to add a cache
in the front of that.
And as clients
scale on that, you
add a cluster in
front of that again.
So it's just chasing the
problem all the way down.
And you keep scaling,
and it never stops.
With BigQuery, push
it all in there,
don't have to worry
about it ever again.
MARTIN OMANDER: And SQL--
Cloud SQL is
somewhat serverful--
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: --as well.
VIKRAM TIWARI:
Yeah, so it's like,
you have to still do the
capacity planning on your side.
They can automatically
do replication.
They will do backups for you.
They will manage it
as a SQL database.
It's not an analytics database.
You want to use BigQuery
as the analytics database
for your workloads, yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: And
you said, Vikram,
that it's easy to get started.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: So is this
something that, perhaps,
when you start building
a proof of concept,
you might go with SQL--
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: --and
then migrate to BigQuery?
Or--
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: --what
are your thoughts?
VIKRAM TIWARI: Depending
upon your needs--
if your needs are not really--
if you see that your clients
are not going to be--
it's either not
too many clients,
or it's not going to be too
many frequent queries, or not
too many aggregations, SQL
might be a perfect fit for you.
And you might have to
maybe go to two or three
tiers of scaling of
your SQL instances.
And you should do that.
It's very easy to get started.
But BigQuery is also easy.
It scales.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, good.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Excellent.
All right, those were
two down, two to go.
The third item, the third
engineering challenge,
is keeping the machine
learning models fresh.
Because as we heard, in
a machine learning lab,
or when you're testing it
out, you might build a model,
and you're done.
But in a real company,
like Vikram's company,
these models have to be
refreshed all the time
for the new data that comes in.
So these models must
be updated all the time
on the latest data.
Could you tell us some
about the challenges
you run into when updating?
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah, sure.
So think of like, when you
build a machine learning model,
it uses--
we used last year worth of
data to build that model.
Now, next day, I'm
getting new data,
which is only 24 hours of data.
But [INAUDIBLE],, I want to make
sure that my model is fresh.
So I will have to use this one
year worth of data plus this 24
hours of data merged
together and then retrain
my whole model.
This works.
But every few days, you're
going to keep increasing
the size of your data.
So the retraining time
will-- every few days,
you will see it increasing.
And there's no way around it.
Or is it?
There is a way.
So we'll talk about
the way in a minute.
Another issue that
we had was we don't
want to keep rebuilding these
models for every new client
that we get.
If all the clients
that we are getting
are trying to do the same
problem over and over again,
you don't want to rebuild
the same model code
and redeploy those same
pipelines all the time.
You want to use
the same version--
same model-- retrain that
model, and utilize that model
for all the clients if you can.
So what we want to use
is a central model,
want to retrain that for the
specific data for the client.
So our initial approach
was using XGBoost.
XGBoost allows us to
build linear models
or random forest-type models.
And you can very easily
scale the parameters in here.
So as we got more
clients, as we got
more different types of clients,
or different types of options
that they wanted to include,
we built a lot of models,
and the model size
was increasing.
So as we see here, initially,
we started with-- on week 1,
we have a smaller model.
On week 2, we get-- model
size keeps getting bigger.
And data also keeps
getting bigger.
The compute time
takes-- getting bigger.
Everything gets-- keeps
getting bigger and bigger.
Model retraining also
takes a lot of time.
Our clients are not
satisfied if you
take more than 24 hours just to
give them real-time predictions
on the new data.
Plus, we have to manually
maintain the whole model
deployment lifecycle.
Every time we get
a new model, you
have to make sure that the
older model gets fazed out.
You want to deallocate the
resources, compute resources,
that are available there.
Maybe you want to keep them.
Because maybe the new model
doesn't work really well,
and you want to really
quickly switch back
to the older version as well.
So there's a lot of
toil that goes in there
in maintaining these models.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, I guess
you could-- theoretically--
end up in a place where it takes
more than 24 hours to process
the last 24 hours--
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: --which
means you never catch up.
VIKRAM TIWARI:
Yeah, and it happens
as soon as you have more clients
and a lot of data coming in.
And you will face that problem.
[LAUGHTER] Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, that
sounds like a good problem.
VIKRAM TIWARI: It's
a good problem.
MARTIN OMANDER: Lots of clients!
VIKRAM TIWARI: I don't
mind the problem.
Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yeah, so one thing
to consider in this
sort of situation
is TensorFlow-- running
TensorFlow on ML Engine, which
is serverless.
You don't have to
set up servers.
It scales better.
You get these check
points and API
versioning that Vikram
was just talking
about-- you get those built in.
So you don't have to
manually deal with them.
And of course-- because
it's serverless--
you can then focus on
your models and not ops.
Is that something that
would fit for Omni Labs?
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah,
so we ended up actually
using TensorFlow on
Machine Learning.
So rather than using
XGBoost models,
we ended up moving all
of that to TensorFlow.
With TensorFlow, it
provides you the ability
to retrain your models,
only on the new data.
We use checkpointing.
With checkpointing,
you train your model
for the one year
worth of data, you
create a checkpoint
on that time.
And next time, when you
have to retrain your data--
your model again today--
you get the new data,
start from the checkpoint,
and you retrain your model
on the new data only.
Training time is much faster.
The only time we have
to take longer time
is when a new client
comes on board
and we have to retrain the
model on the whole of the data.
Then another that we had--
retraining for all
the different clients.
Now with TensorFlow,
there's a concept therein,
called transfer learning.
So we built one big model,
and anytime a new client comes
in, we use transfer learning
to transfer the parameters
and weights that we have
learned-- across our clients--
on to specific.
Based upon the needs
and constraints
of a specific client,
we retrain that model.
And now we have a new model.
And we can keep retraining
our global model
and split off a model
for each client based
upon their own data.
Plus we ended up using a wide
and deep model for this--
I'll talk about
that in a minute.
The best point with this
was we reduced the cost
so much that we don't really
see any increase happening.
It's always a flat line.
MARTIN OMANDER: And
does this mean, then,
that if I come on as
a new customer, maybe
I don't have a whole lot of
data I'm bringing with me--
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: You can still
serve decent predictions
because you have a good model
for all your other clients.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah, so this
helps new clients as well.
Because new clients haven't
tried all the geographies.
New clients haven't tried
all the different parameters
that they can run
their campaigns upon.
Since we have seen this
across our clients,
we can give them optimizations
and recommendations
on how to run their campaigns
because we see a full picture.
And we don't have to wait
for them to get their data.
We know their constraints.
We can retrain the model
based on their constraints.
MARTIN OMANDER: So the
more clients you get,
the smarter your
company becomes.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah,
it feeds on data.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
[? virtuous ?] cycle--
I like that.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah, so I talked
about wide and deep models.
When we started moving away
from XGBoost to TensorFlow,
we stumbled into this.
This was very recent
at that point in time.
Wide models are really
good for memorizing stuff.
So if you want to make
sure that whenever
you are doing a targeting
on and single place,
you want to make sure when you
are targeting San Francisco
you also get Oakland in there.
So those models will
be really good at that,
because they understand this
whole thing is the Bay Area.
Deep models are really
good at generalizing.
So if you want to
target San Francisco,
they might also
suggest to you that you
should try Austin and New York.
Because those are
tech hubs, and it
has learned that
because often those
are deep neural networks--
because of generalization,
their ability to generalize.
But what happens with
deep neural networks
is those are not really
constraint-specific.
You can't put some
constraints in there to say,
I actually don't
want to use this.
So an option is if you
want to get recommendations
for teenagers, you don't really
want adult recommendations
in there.
You just want it for teenagers.
So you want to put those
limitations in there.
For these kinds of
problems that we have--
we have similar problems.
For this, we ended up
merging these two together.
This is not our research--
this was just by Google team.
We used wide and deep models.
There are papers
published for this.
And to do this whole thing, we
could have written whole code
from our side.
But TensorFlow
provides an easy way
to utilize wide and deep models.
They have the
fully-featured API.
All you have to do is
connect your data into it.
You can optimize and
tell it exactly which
features are the cross
features that you
want to utilize-- which ones are
the deep features that you want
to utilize.
You can put your
constants in there.
Plus, you don't
have to manage how
the data will get distributed--
how that training will happen.
TensorFlow will take
care of all of that.
If you put it on
Machine Learning Engine,
it will take care of scaling
the machines for you.
And you can do hyperparameter
tuning as well there.
So you get the best
model architecture
by using wide and deep.
And you get the
best model accuracy
because of using
hyperparameter tuning
on Cloud [? ML ?] Engine.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, so it's kind
of the best of both worlds--
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: --if
you combine them.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Really nice.
All right, so all of this
shuffling data around--
all of this tuning and models.
All of this stuff
accounts for nothing
if you aren't actually able to
make predictions in the end.
So making predictions--
I understand that this is
something where--
you told me customers
come in on Monday morning.
They all sit there.
They all hit the report.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: And then
what used to happen?
What--
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER:
--was the challenge?
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah, so
the challenge that we faced
is nobody cares about
their campaigns on Friday.
Everybody wants their
reports on Monday morning.
And they want all
the suggestions,
because they want to apply
all of the suggestions now.
So every Monday,
in the morning, we
will see a lot of
traffic come in.
MARTIN OMANDER: You couldn't
tell them that, hey you guys,
you start on Tuesday.
[LAUGHTER] You
start on Wednesday.
VIKRAM TIWARI: We
wish, like [INAUDIBLE],,
you can only start
in the morning--
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, yeah.
VIKRAM TIWARI: --at 10:00.
MARTIN OMANDER: They all
wanted it Monday morning.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
Everybody wants it in the
morning at the same time.
MARTIN OMANDER:
At the same time.
VIKRAM TIWARI: And that puts
a lot of load on your servers,
no matter how much you scale.
And scaling-- time
to talk about that.
OK.
MARTIN OMANDER: Mm-hmm.
VIKRAM TIWARI: So the
approach that we went with--
OK, if we are seeing
more traffic come in,
let's increase the machine size.
Let's add more machines
into this cluster.
As we see more and
more users come in,
we kept increasing
those machines.
But it's not really
possible all the time.
Because you can keep
increasing the machines,
but from Thursday to Sunday
evening, nobody is using those.
Nobody is creating on those.
So all the machines that
you have scaled up there,
you're just paying--
I don't mind paying them.
But I don't want to
pay them all the time.
MARTIN OMANDER: Please pay us.
Yes.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah, what
would happen, though,
on Monday morning, no matter
how much we had scaled it up,
it would still go to 100% CPU,
because everybody's trying
to do it at the same time.
Everybody is
creating the servers.
And machines would
become unresponsive.
You don't really want
your machines to go down.
All the hard work that we did--
on getting that data,
transforming it,
putting it everywhere, building
these machine learning models--
all of that fails if you
are not able to serve
your clients properly.
MARTIN OMANDER: So what
would actually happen?
Would they crash?
Would they slow down?
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER:
What would you see?
VIKRAM TIWARI: So
it starts with--
the first person who
gets to the query
gets their result
really quickly.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
VIKRAM TIWARI: But after
that, it slowly and gradually
starts slowing down.
MARTIN OMANDER: Uh-huh.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Unless we see
it, and we increase the machines
in the cluster.
But it gradually slows down,
and once the CPU reaches 100%,
it just becomes unresponsive.
Nobody's getting any
predictions today.
MARTIN OMANDER: Nobody
is getting anything.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, yeah--
no good.
OK, so it sounds like a
very variable load here.
And a lot of systems have that.
I mean most systems
that all of us build
are probably very variable.
Not very many people are hitting
our stuff at 3:00 AM, right?
But there are more
people hitting it, say,
Monday morning.
So one possibility
here is to let
Google handle the scaling up
and down with Cloud Functions.
Cloud Functions is
sort of a gateway--
it can be one of your gateways
into the Google Cloud.
Once the user hits a Cloud
Function endpoint-- an HTTP--
you can now code, in
there, that they can then
hit Cloud Storage, Machine
Learning, Bigtable--
all these other products that
are in the Cloud Platform.
And that ingestion point--
that Cloud Function is
that gateway into GCP.
It scales up and
also scales down,
so you don't pay when
people aren't using it.
Would that be a good fit for
this Monday morning problem?
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
So with Cloud Functions,
there's no server management.
It automatically
scales up and down.
You only pay when you
are running your code.
And it runs in
response to the events.
That's the best part.
Plus, it connects and extends
to all of the existing Google
Cloud Functions that we have--
all the internal systems,
either Machine Learning Engine
or any other APIs that we have.
So that's what we
ended up doing.
Our new approach was
to go serverless.
We went with Cloud Functions.
Our error rate and latency
dropped to almost zero.
It's still an error,
because users are now
trying to get predictions
on very different data
or something that our
model doesn't exist even.
Or a totally new
client who wants
to get their predictions
just right now without even
running any campaigns.
And people do that.
So we were able to scale up.
On Monday mornings,
as the load came in,
it will automatically scale up.
And whenever there is
no more requests coming
in-- on Thursday until Sunday--
it will just scale down itself.
To write that code, it's
really simple actually.
It's one single file that we
use across all of our clients.
What we do is whenever
a different client comes
in, all of those model names
and authentication parameters--
along with the
data that they want
to request to get
predictions upon--
all of those get passed
into one single endpoint.
And based upon that, we
make the correct request
to Machine Learning Engine
to get the predictions.
And one single point enables
all of this scale up and down.
We don't have to
manage all the code.
It's just one single
piece of code to manage.
We don't-- error handling is in
there, because errors happen.
Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Errors do happen.
VIKRAM TIWARI: So to wrap up--
initially this was
our approach where
we were hoping for no alerts.
You can hope for that, but
you will still get that.
As you can see, our
failover replica
was also getting
100% usage in there.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, you
had a failover replica.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: And
the failover fell over.
[LAUGHTER]
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah, you can
never have too much compute.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, yeah.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah,
so we started--
we had Compute Engine for
our serving instances.
We had Compute for our
Machine Learning tasks.
data [? injection ?] tasks.
Everywhere, it was
Compute Engine.
But we moved from there into a
completely serverless solution
where we focus only upon what
matters for our business.
So clients now query
to Cloud Functions.
Cloud Functions get the
predictions from ML Engine.
And on the other
side, we query and get
all the raw data
from external APIs,
using Cloud Dataflow, post it to
BigQuery, and Google Storage--
Cloud Storage for our machine
learning modeling tasks.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Oh, it's all right.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
I was going to say,
you make it sound
very easy here-- yeah,
we were used to it
this way, and 100% CPU.
And we just switched over.
I mean, you're a
smart guy, Vikram,
but could you tell us a
little bit about your journey
from the server-full world
to the serverless world.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER:
It may have been--
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: --a lot of work.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Sure, so yes,
serverless works really well.
But the best thing to
do-- that you can do--
is trust the Google, or any
other serverless solution,
but verify on your end.
And no, you don't
need blockchain.
So to do this, the
best way to get set up
is set up your
monitoring and alerts.
You want to make sure
that your services are up.
And you are constantly
monitoring--
like we did for BigQuery.
We wanted to monitor how
our queries were doing.
So we are looking at the latency
for our BigQuery queries.
So monitoring and
alerts will make sure
that your systems are up.
And they are actually doing as
you would expect them to do.
But sometimes, you actually
need a view into the systems.
The systems are black boxes.
You can't really SSH into
these machines and [? tail ?]
the logs.
So what you want
to do is you want
to set up the systems in
there so you can actually
get the logs in the real time.
So we use Stackdriver
Logging, which
enables us to get all the
logs from all these clusters
that automatically
scale up and down.
You don't have to do
anything in there.
And it will just get all
these logs to this one
central platform for logging.
And you must write the
good code, but I don't.
[LAUGHTER] And so, we still
need other tracking in there.
Because there are
some exceptions
that only happen on
servers in production.
So for that, we ended up using
a Stackdriver Error Tracking.
So any exceptions that we
are not catching-- there
are a lot of times
that you deploy
something in the real time,
and you make mistakes.
So make sure that
there's something that
can catch those exceptions.
And rather than failing
abruptly, you fail gracefully.
MARTIN OMANDER: And you drew
some blue hexagons here.
Let's just make
sure I understood.
The first one-- for
monitoring and alerts--
that was Stackdriver--
VIKRAM TIWARI:
Stackdriver monitoring.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yeah, and for logging,
it was Stackdriver--
VIKRAM TIWARI:
Stackdriver Logging.
It's so easy.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Oh, I have a guess
what the last one is called--
Stackdriver Error Tracking?
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: So the
cool thing with these
is that they are all
serverless-- you don't have set
up servers that
manage the monitoring
and logging and error tracking.
If you have a Google Cloud
Platform project today,
you can just click on the
hamburger menu up on the left
and turn on these
services in your account.
But you did-- so you
set all of this up.
This took some time--
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah, yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: --to
migrate everything over.
VIKRAM TIWARI: So
our whole journey--
it's not turnkey solution.
It takes time to rewrite
your code from Python
to Apache Beam.
And using a big
Node.js project--
to one single function-- to
do all these predictions,
it took some time.
And adding all these
features in there--
so this is a multi-year journey
that took almost a year,
end to end, to build
all these solutions
and run it totally serverless.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yeah, all right--
very good.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: If you could
do the last slide, Vikram.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Let's do it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Let's do
it, should you or I click?
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, you clicked.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Yes.
MARTIN OMANDER: Excellent.
BOTH: So solve business
problems, not engineering
problems, and go serverless.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]